a South Korean man has just been
sentenced to 18 months in prison for
playing pubg well sort of after refusing
to do his mandatory military service as
a conscientious objector the court
investigated the authenticity of his
pacifism and it turns out his love for
the Battle Royale might have sealed his
[Music]
fate several countries across the globe
have some form of mandatory military
service with South Kore just being one
notable example primarily to bolster
their border to the north the majority
of able-bodied men are required to
complete 18 to 21 months of service and
just like any other sort of draft for as
long as Korea has done this young men
have been trying to get out of it which
is exactly what the subject of this case
tried to do according to the original
report from the Korean Herald the
unnamed defendant who was first charged
back in 2018 argued that he should be
exempt due to his moral stance against
quote all war and violence conscientious
obors like this have existed throughout
history and even include plenty of
notable people like Muhammad Ali during
his protest of the Vietnam War but like
Ali these pleas usually don't work and
still lead to severe punishments and
even imprisonment and what do you know
this doesn't fly in Korea either
the man's excuse was dismissed and he
was sentenced to a year and a half in
prison however like I said this is often
the case for conscientious objectors
what makes this story more interesting
is the specific reasoning behind the
Court's decision according to the herald
and the other Publications that reported
on this the court said among many other
things that quote the defendant has not
put any effort into spreading or
realizing what he says is his
ideological belief such as working at an
NGO related to antiviolence anti-war or
peace so yeah basically what the Court's
saying here is the gentleman didn't
practice what he preached and sure maybe
I sort of understand this rationale but
I wouldn't think I'd need to be a
garbage man to prove that I care about
the protocols of recycling but besides
that the real reason we're here is the
secondine line which is even more
targeted and bizarre the verdict
continues quote the defendant admitted
that he frequently enjoyed playing the
game Battlegrounds which is a game about
killing characters with guns in a
virtual reality Yes you heard that
correctly the man's steam playtime was
used against him in court all jokes
aside it is hard to stress just how
concerning this line of reasoning is
essentially what the Court's trying to
do is equate violence in video games
with violence in real life as many of
you know this unsubstantiated claim has
been circulating amongst concerned
parents and lawmakers for years now in
the western world but hearing it used in
a Korean Supreme Court in 2024 is not
something I would have ever expected
they do acknowledge that the world of
video games is different from our own
reality but they continue to hammer home
that if he likes to shoot people in
video games he might not actually be
that much of a pacifist now given
Korea's long history with Prosecuting
draft evaders one can only assume that
their decision was always going to go
this way but it still sets a bad
precedent bringing up things like his
career choice or pubg battle pass
progression could be nothing but a
simple gotcha but it makes it seem like
the government can and will use
completely unrelated things from your
personal life against you in court
obviously World governments love to do
like this but it's still a scary
situation one that's even more bizarre
given Korea's weird history with draft
exemptions outside of individuals living
with severe medical conditions there are
certain people who can find exemptions
usually prestigious artists and athletes
but it should be noted you got to win
something first at the 1986 Asian Games
and the 1988 Summer Olympics athletes
could be guaranteed exemptions if they
want to medal same goes with the
country's national soccer team back in
2002 if they made it to the round of 16
certain classical artists can get the
same treatment if they win an
international competition and as many of
you may now know back in 2022 Faker yes
that Faker and the rest of the Korean
League of Legends team were all given
exemptions after winning the Asian games
so maybe the issue wasn't that the
defendant liked violent video games
maybe it was because he just wasn't good
enough at them yes this case had likely
more to do with the court trying to
prove whether or not this man was an
actual authentic pacifist but that's not
going to be the point that people take
away from this ruling the point is
having to win your way out of
conscription is as dystopian as the
video games you enjoy to play in your
spare time having any effect on whether
or not you go to jail in 2018 the Korean
Supreme Court finally legalized
conscientious objection as a basis for
avoiding military service with the
release of over 50 mostly Jehova's
Witness Prisoners the stipulation for
these exemptions is that the government
would find alternative services for them
to participate in the only question is
why was that not awarded to this man
maybe pubg played more of a role in this
situation than we'd all like to stomach
we just don't know right now so we'll
just have to wait as the story gains
more mainstream media attention to see
if we'll get any new
[Music]
information